what's going on guys this is rob and
after finishing up spider-man i was like
you know like let's let's let's find
something else to cover right something
else to go over here and that's one of
the struggles as a comic book youtuber
is you kind of find yourself in this
position from time to time where you get
so caught up in a story that you're
reading that it's kind of hard to forget
there's still like a mountain of other
stuff there and devil's reign is one of
them this story is amazing okay so it's
basically the return of kingpin not
really the return it's marvel actually
doing something with kingpin now as
opposed to you know like you know king's
ransom or whatever it was so here's the
thing right this story kicks off about a
week ago and it basically picks up with
daredevil as you would expect because
kingpin was originally a daredevil
villain so marvel's
really in recent years kind of taken him
back now one of the things that i do
want to establish here is that right now
kingpin is basically the mayor of new
york city now for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar with this this
has been going on for quite some time
and it all really goes back to secret
empire right so secret empire of course
was a story that we covered where
basically the red skull used a cosmic
cube to change captain america's history
uh and that basically led to captain
america becoming what was essentially a
hydra agent and then conquering north
america where this site sets on the
world although ultimately you know he
was defeated before he could do that and
so the way this played out is that one
of the things that had happened is that
new york itself was basically encased in
living darkness right technically it was
called the dark force but it was
essentially just covered in like encased
in darkness so no one could get in and
no one could get out what you did have
was a character by the name of dagger
who had the ability to emit light and
she was literally tasked with standing
at the top of the empire state building
and just lighting the place up now by
and large people did what they could
where they could and heroes that were
stuck there were trying to find a way
out and trying to find a way to save the
world all that kind of separately safe
you know their city and so on and so
forth but on the street level on the
ground level the average person living
in their homes with no idea what was
happening they had to deal with being
robbed or you know all kinds of
different criminal actions that were
going on and so what the kingpin did is
he actually stepped in and essentially
served as a protector for the city of
new york now make no mistake he knew
what he was doing he knew that in doing
so it would rally the support of the
people so that when the time came when
new york was freed from from its dark
force encasement and basically
everything went back to normal or at
least as normal as you can get in marvel
comics kingpin ran for mayor and the
people elected him right because
basically he was the one that kept them
safe when they had to worry about being
robbed and all that kind of crazy stuff
now the other part of this equation and
this is what he's talking about when
he's speaking with daredevil right that
when he's kind of talking to him and
whatnot that he knows that in his vault
was basically the secret identity of
daredevil but when he went through it
recently that identity was gone right he
doesn't know what in the world's going
on he's essentially lost his knowledge
of daredevil's identity that actually
goes back to daredevil with issue number
twenty really it was volume five issue
number twenty but basically the purple
children so the way this worked you guys
have all heard of the purple man zebedee
kilgrave one of the things that he had
done is he had basically traveled around
really the you know north america and
the world finding all these different
children that he had fathered when he
was being a sadistic person and the goal
was to actually conquer various
countries around the world with his
children running those different
countries or those huge sections of the
world and then they would all basically
report to him once the children were all
gathered together they realized that
they had the power to topple zebedee
kilgrave which they basically did but
while this was going on daredevil was
actually traveling around trying to
rescue them keep them safe different
things like that the idea of kilgrave
was to eventually take their their
powers kind of hook them up to a machine
and use that machine to basically
amplify his own abilities and then
effectively conquer the world and where
all that was basically done one of the
things that happened that marvel had
done is they had basically had this
circumstance set up where the machine
was used to make everyone forget that
daredevil was matt murdock they
literally one more date his storyline
i mean i don't really know if people
were upset by it in all reality i had i
actually had to go back and read that i
hadn't really been keeping up on
daredevil recently but that's really how
all this really kind of picks up right
the things that are going on that are
kind of leading into this now the fact
that kingpin doesn't remember the
identity of daredevil is not the biggest
thing in the world instead what actually
happens is matt torments him right matt
makes fun of him and kind of pokes fun
at him he's like hey man like that's why
it's called a secret identity because
you're not supposed to know and kingpin
actually takes this as a personal
vendetta right he takes this as a
personal affront and so following that
what he does a week later is he steps
out in front of the mayoral office in
new york holds a press conference and
basically civil wars the place in the
sense of saying that like all
superhumans out there are basically
outlawed anybody out there who is
operating as a superhero that's a
problem and it's interesting the way
that he does this right because for the
most part people can think for
themselves but they usually choose not
to they usually just choose to allow a
person an authority to tell them what to
do and rightfully so right it's easier
to do what you're told than to kind of
like try to figure it all out for
yourself and so because of this kingpin
stepping out here and with people
trusting him the way that he does he
says like at the end of the day like
we've suffered wave after wave of
attacks right of destruction brought
down on our great city and at the heart
of almost every single one of those are
superheroes that yes we could look at
villains and we could say villains do
bad things and we deal with them
accordingly but the reign of aliens that
descended down on our city spider-man
originally brought them here of course
he's referencing the events of king and
black and saying it all goes back to
peter parker that the hordes of trolls
and ice-streamed beasts that destroyed
our homes that's because we brought thor
here right that was the war of realms
the idea that like the frost giants and
all all that kind of craziness and chaos
eventually found itself on the doorstep
of earth specifically in the city of new
york and what he says here is there's a
saying follow the money but with these
tragedies it's instead follow the
destruction and you'll find it leads
back to these heroes we allow these
unnatural monsters in capes and bright
colors free reign in a city of good
people people trying to live their lives
and when we dare hold them accountable
for their crimes like with the murderer
daredevil they get preferred treatment a
slap on the wrist and then they're free
to go to do what they've always done
whatever it is that they want to do
terrorizing violence destruction and
that's one of the things that's kind of
the nature of this right the question
here is is the juice worth the squeeze
is the collateral damage that we
experience as a city worth having these
superheroes or would we just be better
off without them and so he says we here
in new york city feel that is not enough
over the last few weeks i've been
working with lawmakers to draft the
powers act recently our friends of the
federal level wisely outlawed
unsanctioned superhero activity for
those under 21 years or age and so he in
turn says we're expanding that right
we're basically outlawing superhero
activity at all here in new york unless
it's sanctioned so in a lot of ways this
really is the superhuman registration
act from civil war it's renamed and it's
largely being confined in the city of
new york but it's cool because if i'm
being honest with you guys as much as i
loved the civil war event i kind of
think this is a little more interesting
because it brings things kind of closer
to home right one of the first questions
that people ask is like is the rest of
the country going to follow suit are
other cities going to follow the same
process remember with the superhuman
registration act it was just a
nationwide crackdown like that right
just day one everyone has to register
with this act it's a little more extreme
and even tony stark says that right he's
like we've been down this road before
superheroes serve a purpose and have
saved not only new yorkers but the world
many times over this is a desperate move
from a gangster mayor in an election
year even krakow steps in right and like
storm sets up and says look cricoa
doesn't really care about law about
man's laws right so do not mess with us
and we will not mess with you right
mutants everywhere have diplomatic
immunity no matter where they go and so
that really supersedes anything that the
city of new york is doing but rest
assured if a mutant travels to new york
city and they are arrested by the forces
of wilson fisk there will be hell to pay
right i mean it's just that's kind of
the stance of kakoa which is really cool
and then following that the first wave
of arrests begin for those individuals
who basically just refuse to well to
register if we're going to call with
that and of course moon knight's the
first one
why wouldn't it be mark specter right i
mean the guy's like the guy's marvel's
batman i mean of course he's not going
to register but then from there you
actually end up getting what's
essentially the thunderbolts right
that's what we're just going to call i
mean they're kind of the newly formed
thunderbolts here right so like rhino us
patriot and it looks like shriek and
then of course like the female electro
maxine so like you have like these these
you know kind of superheroes who are
here but they're quote unquote
registered and that's why this event is
very reminiscent of civil war and i'm
sure those of you guys who read civil
war like okay so it's basically just
civil war on a smaller scale and you're
not wrong
you are by no means wrong because even
during the civil war event the
thunderbolts were the group that were
tasked with like going out and like
breaking laws if they needed to in order
to get their hands on people who were
refusing to register and that leads into
the introduction of captain america
right who basically tells these cops
these enforcers to essentially lay off
and that when they refuse to do it then
everything kind of starts to pop off
here now of course captain america steps
in to basically save miles more alice of
course miles has a new costume which
looks dope i'm not even gonna lie we
need to get caught up on miles comics
right like i love miles morales and i'm
never gonna get used to miles being in
the in like the main marvel universe so
seeing like captain america come to his
aid right like the maine marvel universe
steve rogers it's always going to be new
to me right it's always going to be cool
to me like it's just it's it's one of
those fun little things but it's kind of
interesting right because this is one of
those instances where captain america
very reminiscent of civil war of course
tony stark really seems to be on his
side too but captain america's response
here like where the guards tell him like
you know like you're under arrest too
cap like every one of you guys are
under-arrested captain america was like
okay i mean that's cute and everything
bro like i totally understand you your
belief that you can arrest me and and
that's adorable right it's like a little
kid sitting on santa's lap saying what
it is they want for for christmas you
know it's cute and it makes for a good
picture let's be honest with ourselves
man there's nothing you can do to me
here but i will absolutely beat you to
death before that happens i mean he
won't but like that's kind of his stance
and so in this conversation one of the
guys says like well i mean this guy is a
criminal and the response to captain
america is if if a law needs to be
broken in order to save lives i'll do it
every single time and so ultimately the
other guys are like no you guys are all
going in and so of course captain
america helps them to understand their
place in the bigger picture by cracking
them over the head with a shield which
is always the best to answer like i
always tell you guys violence is not
always the answer but it is a answer and
it's usually a very effective one right
violence gets things done and captain
america understands that right like
captain america understands violence
gets things done i mean are there gonna
be problems sure but it's an answer
[Laughter]
so sometimes you just gotta well at
least no pun intended roll with the
punches you know what i mean
but at the same time you've also got
like spider-man and daredevil who step
in so in a lot of ways it's a coming
together of the superhero community
standing directly against wilson fitz
now of course they end up basically kind
of going to an underground lair and
that's when the questions start getting
asked like why is wilson fisk doing this
and initially matt murdock steps up and
says actually it's my fault and and the
reason he really takes the blame on this
is one because of what we saw in the
beginning with regards to the fact that
wilson fisk knew what daredevil's
identity was but daredevil had basically
engineered a circumstance to make him
forget and the fact that daredevil had
taunted him but in the end the response
here is no there's no way that's that's
the case i mean like we knew and even
captain america says that we knew from
the time that wilson fisk was elected to
office it was only a matter of time
before something like this happened
right like lest we forget wilson fisk is
the kingpin of crime or at least he was
the kingpin of crime he was never a good
guy so i understand what you're saying
daredevil and sure you being a dick
probably had something to do with this
but at the end of the day like wilson
fisk was only ever going to do this at
some point in time right all roads were
going to lead to this so it's not
entirely your fault now of course this
leads to the forces of wilson fisk
specifically the authorities showing up
at the baxter building and the reason
why is because the backstreet building
of course is working on what would be
perceived as weapons of mass destruction
it's not really their intention to do
that but they're toying with things like
antimatter and so on and so forth any
one of the devices that they're
experimenting with if used for nefarious
purposes could obliterate the entire
city the funny thing about this is that
because of the nature of reed richards
and because of the fact that the
experiments he works on the things that
he does really kind of transcend any
immediate benefit to like the city of
new york and are really more for the
benefit of society as a whole he
basically gets a kind of free pass from
the federal government right where he
basically gets this kind of system where
it's like work on whatever you want to
work on just make sure you don't use it
against humanity because we know that
ultimately it's going to benefit us all
the problem with this is that because of
what's going on with the powers act that
basically the federal government is kind
of turning a blind eye to the idea of
what it is that that reed richards and
all them are working on so in effect
they've been thrown under the bus now
initially where the fantastic four or at
least reed and susan are like okay this
ain't gonna happen right and they
immediately start taking up arms they're
suddenly met by the arrival of dr
octopus who basically slaps on inhibitor
callers right callers that basically
neutralize their powers and it's like
yeah man the federal government's left
you hanging guys uh i don't know what to
tell you and so all they really end up
doing here is basically sounding the
alarm and basically telling johnny storm
and uh and ben grimm as well as valeria
and franklin that it's a code x7 right
basically the baxter building's being
invaded now here's one of the funny
things about this right it's not the
first time we've seen this happen and i
was kind of disappointed with how this
transpired right if you guys remember
during dark rain when jonathan hickman
first started writing the fantastic four
that like norman osborne the green
goblin when he was director of shield
invaded the baxter building to take it
over and franklin richards dressed as a
cowboy pointed a faint gun at him but
because he had reality warping powers he
shot him with a real bullet like it was
amazing it was just like like it was
small little moments like that when you
saw like franklin's just reality warping
power but ben graham basically steps in
and ends up just kind of snatching him
up along with johnny storm and they
effectively take off and then that's
basically it right i mean they get out
of there as fast as they can at that
point it switches over to luke cage and
jessica jones obligatory appearance of
the comics the reason why i say
obligatory is because this is one of
those instances where jessica jones
appears so that marvel can remind us she
still exists well like she's still there
guys uh she's she still exists in mobile
comics just so you know here's some
stories that involve her she is there
with luke cage and luke cage was
supposed to have a tie into this event
but basically they ended up canceling it
and i don't know why because he has an
amazing moment here but basically like
where he and jessica jones are like i
mean yeah let's lay low it's why we
don't do costumes right because we don't
draw attention to ourselves i mean
granted like luke cage led the mighty
avengers at one point so people know who
they are but it's very easy to lay low
when you're wearing just like some kind
of a coat and like a black shirt and
some cargo pants or jeans and just kind
of calling it a day right where
initially they were content with just
kind of staying quiet keeping to
themselves you know making sure they
didn't draw any attention there's this
great big huge calamity that happens and
basically luke cage ends up you know
getting involved and stepping in only to
be met by the arrival of the shocker uh
who's working as part of the
thunderbolts and where the thunderbolts
would have would have initially had
their hands on this albeit in a pretty
unsavory way right i mean they're pretty
reckless and they don't really much care
about like preserving human life so long
as they quote unquote in the threat that
where shocker ends up throwing one of
these collars to luke cage and it's like
put this on and put this on your wife
luke cage is like huh not a chance right
and then like a fight breaks out between
the two right now ultimately of course
luke cage is able to get the upper hand
and able to subdue the shocker and the
two of them basically end up fleeing but
before they do he makes this really
really amazing speech right he says like
this isn't right he's like wilson fisk
is a gangster and a fool a big man who's
small who needs to show his power over
me my friends and you this is not just
about superheroes it's about a man with
his grip on all of us he makes it sound
like if he loosens it you'll all
basically be in trouble some villain
will show up or something like that the
kind of trouble that shows him that it's
actually you who has the power here he
says look i'm not captain america i'm
not mr fantastic he says i'm just a new
yorker just like you and if someone's in
trouble i will do what new yorkers do i
help and if mayor fisk wants to stop me
that's fine that's a genius speech
because what it does is it forces people
to accept the fact that they are
contributors to the problem right and
and it's one of the things about on a
societal level that people tend to
forget right it's very easy to kind of
adopt this mentality that like
everything bad that happens in the world
is because of some invisible specter
moving behind the scenes but like every
major problem that happens in the world
is because of people like there's no
invisible force out there causing
problems it's people who are doing
terrible things and with luke cage
pointing his finger at everybody out
there and saying that if this continues
on it's because you're allowing it right
by doing nothing you're saying you're
okay with it if you weren't okay with it
you would do something about it right
you can't be apathetic and then say well
i'm empathetic because there's nothing i
can do no that's just laziness
masquerading as apathy and so by
pointing that finger at them and saying
you're the reason why this is happening
it's forcing at least someone or at
least driving somebody to acknowledge
the fact that they are the problem and
so following that what you actually end
up doing is switching over to kingpin
when he goes to join butch now butch
ferris is an interesting character this
guy was basically a henchman of the owl
for quite some time the owl being a d
less villain at best right like this guy
was never ever ever ever big time but
the perception here of butch as the new
kingpin of crime and even before he
became the kingpin of crime working his
way up the ranks and basically you know
knocking heads as well as getting moves
and promotions in the right places
especially by izzy is that he is the
legitimate biological son of wilson fisk
that wilson fisk supposedly had a favor
with his mother a woman named mrs p and
that basically left him as the the real
heir here and so wilson fisk largely
seems to follow that and saying that
he's doing all of this in order to make
life easier for his son that really
seems to be the main motivation behind
why fisk is doing this i wouldn't say
that's simply it and fisk is one to play
the long game so if this is the
perception he's putting off to uh to
butch ferris i'd say he may very well be
pulling a ruse and so following that
where basically he tells kingpin like
get out of here you're basically met
with mike murdock now mike murdock oh oh
my god okay marvel had this genius idea
at one point in time that matt murdock
operating on the ground level because he
didn't want people to know that he was
uh that he was daredevil had fabricated
this identity called mike murdock and it
wasn't like he suffered with identity
disorder he didn't have like a multiple
personality disorder or anything i mean
he did kind of have a personality
disorder in the more recent run but mike
murdock was ultimately just a concept
that he had created there was one point
in time when daredevil was working with
the inhumans and one of them their name
escapes me had the ability to basically
bring to life anything they read and in
reading about matt murdock had basically
learned that matt had created the mike
murdock persona and accidentally made
him tangible following that it's just a
series of events where mike murdock just
kind of became his own person doing his
own thing and all that kind of stuff i
mean this also goes in line with the
fact that um that the entire history of
matt murdock had basically been
rewritten which is weird honestly i
don't know how long this is gonna go on
for i imagine marvel's just gonna retcon
all this away and it's just gonna go
back to matt murdock just being matt
murdock and that's basically gonna be it
but because of the life that he created
for himself mike murdock and butch
ferris had basically kind of just grown
up as friends who were also involved in
the criminal underworld and so that's
why the success of butch is also the
success of mike and also because mike
kind of helped him progress a little bit
right mike had masqueraded as daredevil
different things along those lines but
it had been instrumental in butch coming
to power as the new kingpin of crime and
so following that you switch back over
to to luke cage and jessica jones and
jessica jones of course is like yeah you
know we we gotta get out of here and all
that kind of stuff but when they get out
there they're met by tony stark and so
tony stark's like yeah guys we gotta do
something about this okay cool whatever
tony like
i mean he wants to get rid of him right
because a lot of it's jessica jones
making this case about how kingpin is is
basically overthrowing democracy or at
least seems to be making himself
totalitarian she doesn't really know how
tony stark feels about that because the
last time there was a major catastrophe
like this right civil war tony stark
cited against the superhero community
and in favor of registration but in the
end stark's like no it's it's different
this time one because i've arbitrarily
decided it and two because it's not
exactly like it was with civil war with
civil war there was a tangible reason
why the superhuman registration act was
being passed right that nitro had
detonated in stanford connecticut he'd
killed men women and children and so
with all that death and destruction that
catalytic event people were like we're
done right like that's it right that
catalyst had to like set things off
they're like we're finished right we're
done with collateral damage and all that
kind of stuff the superhero community
needs to be held accountable for the
things they say and do right superhuman
registration is the way to go wilson
fisk is using existing scenarios to
paint this kind of dark and sinister
series of events in some unguaranteed
future that may or may not come to pass
if superheroes are not held accountable
i guess maybe civil war kind of did the
same thing but nonetheless you see what
i'm saying right he's using
circumstances as a reason to justify the
launch of an event that in all honesty
couldn't even have been stopped by the
superhero community an eldritch demon a
primordial being from the void that
existed before the universe finally gets
free and attacks earth right i mean
there's nothing superheroes could have
done to prevent that
right so so using these almost
unpreventable circumstances as a reason
to explain why it is that these kind of
restrictive policies need to be
implemented that's the difference
between civil war and this we're kind of
nitpicking a bit to be honest but you
know we got to create a different
somehow so we're not just saying it's
civil war like civil war three just on a
smaller scale but the other thing about
this is we actually end up finding out
that basically dr octopus is working on
something for wilson fisk and it seems
to be some kind of portal that accesses
you know another dimension we don't know
exactly what it's for or what it does
but it looks to be the bridge that reed
richards had constructed during jonathan
hickman's run the same bridge technology
they used when it came to like the
incursions from avengers and new
avengers and all that kind of stuff but
wilson fisk ultimately you know cuts dr
octopus offices like the package is here
and that's when you find out wilson
frisk has actually freed the purple man
zebedee kilgrave from prison and it's
kind of a cool thing here because what
he does is like he goes through this
folder that kilgrave has and he's like
do you know what this folder is and
where kilgrave's like i don't know right
because he always thinks small he's like
this this this folder is power right
because it represents knowledge it
represents information that i can use
because in a lot of ways wilson fisk in
marvel comics is very much a j edgar
hoover kind of guy right for those of
you guys who don't know who that is j
edgar hoover was the head of the fbi at
one point in time and he had information
on everyone some say he was the most
powerful man in the world right because
they had information on everyone right
foreign dignitaries citizens government
officials that if j edgar hoover wanted
it j edgar hoover got it and in fact
after j edgar hoover left the fbi there
were sweeping changes to the power of
the fbi director because of the threat
that j edgar hoover represented that
people who were talking if you go back
and you read any of like those old
interviews and those old books or
anything like that people were like that
guy could have become a dictator the
only reason he didn't is because he
chose not to i mean this guy could do
virtually anything he wanted to in law
enforcement kingpin is very much the
same way he really operates a lot like j
edgar hoover as well kind of operating
behind the scenes using the knowledge he
has to force people to you know create
policies or to avoid laws or make laws
that are beneficial to him the problem
with this is that as he's talking to
kilgrave he's like this folder has
nothing to use against you right there's
nothing here your children hate you they
want to have you dead so i can't use
that against you you have no loved ones
you have nothing there's nothing that i
can use against you here but in a lot of
ways that's always what kilgrave wanted
kilgrave always wanted to have this kind
of scenario where where he could never
really have anything used against him
because he never had anything at all but
at the end of the day when he goes to
basically use his powers on wilson fisk
it doesn't work and the reason why is
because wilson fisk is one of those very
very few number of individuals that
exists out there where his will power is
so strong that zebedee kilgrave's powers
cannot work on him that's one of the
things to know kilgrave does not use
mind control in the traditional sense
it's not telepathy he emits pheromones
but a person with a substantial level or
a high enough level of fortitude right
the ability to withstand the effects of
killgrave they can overcome him his
powers will have no effect on them
whatsoever and so ultimately wilson fisk
seizes zebedee kilgrave and is just like
done he's like what a squandered gift he
says perhaps it's time someone more
worthy possessed it and so ultimately it
looks like he kills zebedee kilgrave
seemingly for the purpose of attaining
his power and using him for himself the
other thing that we end up finding out
is that wilson fisk has a sight set much
much higher than mayor of new york what
he's shooting for is to become president
of the united states and it looks like
he will do it in the same way most
politicians will do it which is by any
means necessary beg borrow steal or kill
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace